我们在历史的洪流下，
在一些这种大的经济形势的洪流下，
我们每一个人都是一粒尘埃，
很多东西也不是我们的错，
也不是说么对错能说得了的事情，
泥沙俱下的时候，
我们只不过是很不幸，
就是那小小的一粒尘埃，
对于这些房子被腰斩了，
被脚踝斩了，
房价跌了，
那么多的朋友我都是这种心态，
活着最重要，
我想知道这个房子如果他是打开的话，
他的这个流程是怎么样的。
第二个问题是我们现在这个房子是夫妻双方的名字，
打开之后，
他剩余的款项还是由夫妻双方去还呢？
两个人都会被列入，
就是被执行人还是什么这样的一个情况，
你的这个房子登记在谁的名下，
那然这个房子登记的是夫妻双方的名字，
购买的发票金额是160万，
但是我们首付是48点几万，
具体多少忘记了，
反正就是不到50万，
二年年底还是二三年年初买的，
当时是因为小孩要上学的时候才买的这个房子现在为什么要法拍，
就是经济的问题，
然后还不上市场价，
现在是多少钱？
现在这个房子的市场价是大概95万，
法拍可能拍不出市场价了。
法拍一般都比市场价要低，
可能是市场价的80%就会被法拍掉了，
估计80都不一定能拍出去吧，
现在直所以说我就想了解一下这个流程是怎么样的后续，
呃，
是双方都会被列入被执行人的这个情况呢？
那得看一下这个法拍的起因是什么，
是谁的原因欠债了还不上了，
要法拍，
因为你们还不上房子的贷款，
要法拍吗？
是的，
如果这个房子是登记在你们个人的名下，
且贷款的时候也是两个人一起贷的，
那么现在还不上贷款要法拍的话，
那么你们两个人都得承担这个后果，
他如何分辨他是两个人一起带还是个人带，
因为名字是两个人的，
但是贷款的时候，
我老公的腿因为当时受伤了，
在住院就是不方便走动，
主代人，
本来要是他后面临时因为出了这个意外，
就变成了我去银行办的这个贷款，
主贷人在我的名下，
那其他就除了主贷人之外，
其他的文件他签字了吗？
他去签字了，
那就是一起的好的，
买这个房子是因为当时孩子读书，
现在房价掉了之后，
我老公就很消极，
我跟他协商了时候，
我说要不这个房贷一年大概得有千万多块钱。
啊，
我说我们一人提供一半，
但是非常的消极，
就一直说这个房子不要了，
他说银行也不能让他怎么办，
因为他已经是被执行人了，
我们之前是有正常的公司，
一个小工厂，
经营不善的各种原因，
现在就已经是关掉了，
应收款和那个欠款它是大概能齐平，
但是这个我们的应收款一直是收不上来的，
这样一个情况，
他现在是很摆烂的一个情况，
咱不能跟钱过不去啊，
都到这一步了，
为什么自己不积极主动的把房子卖了去还银行的贷款呢？
因为你自己卖合法拍的话，
通常自己卖要这个合适一点，
他现在是这个房子卖不掉呀，
那房子为什么会买，
是因为当时我们家小孩要上学才买的，
是，
我跟我老公就属于那一批，
离不掉的那一批，
很尴尬，
在这里主要是因为法泰没有人买，
他就跟我说他身边很多人都断供了，
银行也不能拿他怎么样，
但是我认为应该不是这样子的，
你俩都有工作吗？
都有那个正经工作吗？
我现在工作是自己跟朋友合伙开了一个店，
或者一年能分到我自己身上，
现在生意也不太好做，
每一年大概的收入不稳定啊，
可能就是十几万出头的样子，
那平时还要覆盖家庭的一个开支，
还有小孩的一个。
各种各样的开支，
过去这是一年的房贷，
我能提供一半应该差不多，
我不是说不愿意提供，
我是怕我自己万一我还不上，
我会面临什么样的风险，
我想了解，
其实也就是失信的被执行人嘛，
俗称黑名单啊，
上失信的被执行人就是，
第一钱就不能放在你们名下了，
第二坐不了飞机，
坐不了高铁，
第三进行不了高消费，
第4没有办法再创建公司啊，
自己当什么法人啊什么的，
会受一点影响，
其他的也没啥大影响，
孩子正常读书，
只要不是上那种很贵的私立学校，
也不受影响。
那我跟我老公有一个分歧，
我是主张这个房子要还的，
但是我怕我自己的能力有限，
我还不上，
但是他呢，
倒摆烂，
怪有点怪我的意思，
他就是觉得当时我们可以不买这个房子的，
把他放老家上去也行，
其实他有了看吗，
跟他的情况已经是离不掉的那一批，
也不是说不想离就是离不掉的那一批，
我感觉我能力不够，
我也不知道我现在这个情况该怎么办，
可能百万对于你来说更合适一点，
因为你一个人承担不了，
如果说你说找亲戚朋友帮忙啊，
渡过难关啊什么的，
债就又压到你一个人头上了，
可能白烂，
对于你来说更现实一点，
行，
好，
就这样啊，
好的，
谢谢罗凤姐，
拜拜。
嗯，
我跟所有。
呃，
就是房价被腰斩或者房价被脚踝斩的朋友，
其实我都是这态度，
我觉得这个事情啊，
我们在历史的洪流下，
在一些这种大的经济形势的洪流下，
我们每一个人都是一粒尘埃，
很多东西也不是我们的错，
也不是什么对错能说得了的事情，
泥沙俱下的时候，
我们只不过是很不幸，
就是那小小的一粒尘埃。
对于这些房子被腰斩了，
被脚踝了，
房价跌了那么多的朋友，
我都是这种心态，
活着最重要，
上黑名单这事儿没有那么要命，
他不会逼死我，
反正我活着最重要。
记得点赞关注哦。